active restored the assembly restored
and should there be another election
that result respected as the last result
should be respected John McNally
time for a UK EU deal to be struck the
can the minister commit to the house our
deal will be struck before April next
year and that this Pro brexit district
will not happen it's good Friday
agreement celebrations and the UK's
International conversations with America
and the EU so you stay I I think the
[Music]
foreign
I genuinely didn't think the honorable
gentleman's question was that good
um I I think actually that the normal
gentleman should uh maybe imbibe a bit
of a Christmas festivities because I
think we should be more glass half full
about the opportunities of a negotiated
settlement uh to the protocol issue
which will benefit everybody and all
parties in Newton Northern Ireland
Patricia Gibbs yeah
of the European commission said if
there's a political will issues around
the Northern Ireland protocol could be
resolved within a couple of weeks so
will the minister find the will to reach
a solution to and commit to a timeline
for a deal perhaps before the end of the
six week extension to formal executive
in January
I can generally say to The Honorable
lady that the atmosphere in the
relationships between the European Union
and the United Kingdom government have
changed dramatically in in recent weeks
and months and that is the basis for all
good things
that completes those questions before we
come to the prime minister's questions I
would like to point out the British sign
language interpretation of proceedings
available to watch on Parliament live TV
we start with questions to prime
minister John Stevenson yeah
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I'm minister
Mr Speaker I'm sure the whole house will
share my sorrow at the capsizing of a
small boat in the channel in the early
hours of this morning and the tragic
loss of human life our hearts go out to
all those affected and our tributes to
those involved in the extensive rescue
operation Mr Speaker this is another
thing I had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house including the visit
of his majesty the king I shall have
further such meetings later today John
Stevens thank you Mr Speaker prime
minister a three and a half hour Journey
takes six hours a straight Journey ends
up with two changes and a diversion a
train is canceled at short notice this
has become the experience of a West
Coast rail passenger if Avanti do not
get their act together will the
government cancel their franchise
very popular question
and Mr uh Mr Speaker I thank my
honorable friend for raising this and I
share the frustration that this is
causing to many of his and other
communities our priority immediately is
to support the restoration of services
before then making any long-term
decisions on the operation of the West
Coast franchise but we will be closely
monitoring Avanti's rollout of its
recovery plan and holding then account
for delivering for passengers they did
the opposition kill Starman
uh thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
Prime Minister our prayers go out to
those who capsized in the freezing
Waters of the channel last night it's a
reminder that the criminal gangs running
those routes put the lives of the
desperate at risk and profit from their
misery they must be broken up and
brought to Justice
Mr Speaker tomorrow will be the first
ever Nationwide nurses strike
all the prime minister has to do to stop
that is to open the door and discuss pay
with them if he did the whole country
would Breathe the sight of relief
why won't he
prime minister Mr Speaker we have
consistently spoken to all the unions
involved in all the pay disputes that
there are but I am I am glad he's raised
our nurses because they do do incredible
work and it's worth putting on record
it's worth putting on record what
exactly we have done for our nurses last
year last year when the rest last year
when everyone else in the public sector
had a public sector pay freeze the
nurses received a three percent pay rise
when the RCN asked for more in-work
training we gave every nurse and midwife
a 1 000 pound training budget and when
they asked for nurses bursaries we made
sure that every nursing student received
a 5 000 pound Grant that's because we do
work constructively and we will continue
to back our nurses
the nurses going on strike is a badge of
Shame for this government
instead of showing leadership he's
playing games with people's health
and there is a human cost Alex from
Chester has been waiting for a
gallbladder operation for nearly six
months he's in so much pain he's been
off school since then his operation has
already been canceled twice
his mum who I spoke to this morning is
worried sick
when she heard that strikes could be
called off she was massively relieved
she's desperate for the prime minister
to resolve this all he needs to do is
simply meet the nurses Alex's mum is
listening to this she doesn't want to
hear him blaming everybody else she
doesn't want his usual ducking of the
question she's tuned in now because she
wants him to explain what is he going to
do to resolve the nursing Strife
Mr Speaker it's not just Alex there are
millions of others across this country
millions of others millions of others
who will have their health care
disrupted because of the strike Now The
Honorable gentleman says to get round
the table but we all know what that
means Mr Speaker that is just simply a
political formula for avoiding taking a
position on the this issue
If he if he thinks if he thinks the
strikes are wrong he should say so
[Applause]
that pay demands of 19 are met then he
should say so
what what's weak Mr Speaker is he's not
strong enough to stand up to the union
[Applause]
we know it's Christmas but the past is
not started yet come on
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker in
12 hours time there's a nurse's strike
all he needs to do is meet the nurses
his inaction speaks volumes as ever with
this prime minister it's Tory politics
first patient second
we've never seen a nurse's strike like
this before they've been forced into it
because the government has broken the
health system asked anyone in the NHS
they will tell you they don't have
enough staff 133
000 vacancies and there's an obvious
solution
scrap the non-dom status and use the
money to bring through the next
generation of doctors and nurses that's
what labor would do why hasn't he got
their guts to do it
Mr Speaker we're already investing
billions more in the NHS we're already
hiring thousands more doctors and nurses
but he asked he asked he asked about
backlog he asks about backlogs in the
waiting times in the NHS and yes what he
always fails to acknowledge is the
impact that kovid did Mr Speaker that's
why we're facing pressures but we do
have a plan not just more money not just
more doctors and nurses new diagnostic
Centers carrying out millions of checks
and scans new surgical hubs delivering
more elective surgery but if we'd
listened to him Mr Speaker the backlog
would still be growing and that's
because we'd still be in lockdown
[Applause]
Department his Department commissioned a
report into the NHS which reported on
Monday that report said we've had 10
years of managed decline it was not
covered
responsibility is sitting right there
and the reason he can't choose nurses
over non-doms is because he's too weak
to stand up the tax avoiders
for 12 years they haven't trained enough
doctors and nurses so we have the Absurd
situation of the NHS spending billions
on agency workers to fill the Gap why
should the country have to put up with
money that should be spent treating
patients being wasted plugging gaps
instead
Mr Speaker Let Me Tell The Honorable
gentleman what we are doing we are
actually listening to the independent
pay review bodies
they want to undermine them we've
offered a fair pay deal they can't even
decide on a number amongst themselves
we're actually protecting the public
they're protecting their pay masters Mr
Speaker I do for working people in this
country
for working people in this country it's
Labor's Nightmare Before Christmas
[Applause]
there he goes again pretending
everything is fine try telling that to
those on waiting lists or those that
can't afford to pay for a next day GP
appointment
12 years of Tory failure winter has
arrived for our public services and
we've got a prime minister who has
curled up in a ball and gone into
hibernation
if he can't act on behalf of patients or
nurses or everyone who wants these
strikes called off then surely the whole
country is entitled to us what is the
point of him and what is the point of
the government he's supposed to be
leading
[Applause]
Mr Speaker he talks about covert not
having impact ambulance waiting time for
category one category one ambulance
waiting times in February of 2020 were
actually completely On Target Mr Speaker
cobit has has an impact and that's why
that's why that's why as as the chief
executive of the NHS has acknowledged
this government is serious about its
commitment to prioritize the NHS but Mr
Speaker let's just have a look at the
NHS in labor-run Wales shall we
foreign
the worst a e times in the country Mr
Speaker
after the last Labor government we had
Fair pay for nurses and no strikes so I
went I won't be taking lectures from him
about that
[Applause]
order order Mr Bowie you promised to
behave don't give me a Christmas present
you will won come on
Mr Speaker this is our final pmqs of the
year so I hope you will pop oh really I
hope you will
uh Mr Speaker what I was going to say
was I hope you will pass on all of our
thanks at least on this side to all
those who kept our house and our
democracy working and I want to finish
this year thinking about our friends in
Ukraine as a result of Putin's barbaric
assault on their freedom Millions will
spend Christmas in Sub-Zero temperatures
without heating electricity or hot water
their suffering is unimaginable but
their bravery is awe-inspiring
so will the Prime Minister join me in
saying that whatever other difficulties
and disagreements we have across this
dispatch box
we are and will remain United in our
unwavering support for Ukraine's Freedom
its Liberty and its victory
well Mr Speaker can I join with the
honorable gentleman in thanking and
paying tribute to all the staff of the
house for the Fantastic work that they
do to support all of us and I appreciate
his comments on Ukraine it has been a
point of incredible Unity across this
house and indeed the country something
that we can all be proud of in our
country that we have stood behind
Ukraine at its hour of need and as I
said yesterday this Christmas many
families will be laying an extra place
at their Christmas table and that speaks
to the generosity and compassion of our
nation and long may that continue
thank you Mr Speaker the A3 connects
London to Portsmouth through Guildford
and I was delighted to see the new
solent Freeport announced last week
which will increase traffic flows as the
A3 Narrows through Guildford as a sadly
the most polluted Road in the Strategic
Road Network short-term sticking
plasters like putting up nine meter high
air pollution barriers that will
entrench divisions in Guildford is not
acceptable to me or my constituents does
my right honorable friend agree with me
that it is time to think big it is time
to think long term and it is time to
Tunnel the A3 under Guildford
prime minister well okay I thank my uh I
thank my honorable friend for the
question I know this is an issue that
she is long championed I am told that
National highways are developing a range
of different possibilities and solutions
for the A3 through Guildford and I know
the department for transport will
consider the case as it plans its future
infrastructure Investments SMP leader
Stephen Flynn
yeah I wish to join with the Prime
Minister and the leader of opposition in
extending my party's thoughts to all of
those involved in the terrible tragedy
in the channel this morning Mr Speaker
thanks to positive and proactive
negotiations between the Scottish
government and unite and Unison Health
unions a pay settlement has been reached
in strike action averted by Stark
contrasts the UK Health secretary
appears completely unwilling to
negotiate with unions on pay and strike
action is very much still on the table
so may I ask the Prime Minister when
will he see the error of his ways and
follow the Scottish government's lead
prime minister well Mr Speaker I'm glad
the UK government was able to provide
one and a half billion pounds an extra
uh to the Scottish government for public
services
that the health secretary and other
ministers have engaged fully not just
with the unions but with an independent
pay setting process which takes the
politics out of the process and ensures
that we can meet those independent
requirements with a fair pay deal
Stephen Flynn Mr Speaker let's be clear
those words will ring Hollow in the ears
of those people who unlike the Prime
Minister canning up into waitrose for
their shopping nor indeed even turn on
the heating at this moment in time and
that's particularly too for people in
Scotland because as we know average
energy bills in Scotland are not
anticipated to be 2 500 pounds per year
they're expected to be 3 300 pounds per
year people are genuinely terrified and
that's despite the fact that Scotland
produces six times more gas than we
consume with some 80 of our electricity
coming from low carbon sources Decades
of failed UK energy and Regulatory
policy coming
is it not the case that Scotland has the
energy we just need the power
[Applause]
yeah well Mr Speaker I'm glad the
honorable gentleman raised the question
of energy support
and it's because of the actions of this
government that we are providing every
household in this country with around
900 pounds of support with their energy
bills this winter 55 billion pounds
worth of support and on top of that next
year there will be extra cost of living
payments worth up to 1 200 pounds for
the most vulnerable whether that's those
or means-tested benefits pensioners or
indeed disabled this is a government
that will always look after the most
vulnerable in our society
thank you Mr Speaker as my right
honorable friend will know the mayor of
London despite objections has decided to
expand the Euless Zone across all London
boroughs which will massively impact my
constituents and those who share a
border with London will he therefore
urgently speak to the transport
secretary and encourage him to use the
powers at his disposal to reverse this
disastrous decision
or my uh honorable friend will know that
transport in London is devolved to the
labor mayor of London but it is
disappointing then they're backed by the
leader of the opposition is choosing not
to listen to the public
the zone is being expanded against the
overwhelming views of residents and
businesses and I've urgently consider
them there and the gentleman opposite to
be on the side of hard-working londoners
can I shoot myself from my party with
the comments made by others on the
tragedy in the channel our thoughts and
prayers are with the family's victims
Mr Speaker 40 of cancer patients now ate
more than two months for treatment
after an urgent referral from a GP
that's the highest proportion on record
and way above the government's own
cancer awaiting Target
I lost both my parents to cancer as a
child
and so like many people across the
country and in this house
I know the devastating impact of
treatment delays on cancer patients and
their families
so I'd like to ask the Prime Minister
two questions
first can you give a cast iron guarantee
that the Dreadful cancer backlog won't
get any worse
and second when will the government meet
his own counter Target
prime minister
Mr Speaker I'm very sorry to hear about
the right wrong gentleman's parents
indeed I'm sure many of us across this
house have been been our families have
been tragically affected by what cancer
does and he's right to raise the
importance of meeting our targets and
what I am able to tell him is we
actually are experiencing very high
numbers of cancer referrals following
the pandemic he'll be aware of that but
thanks to the brilliant work of our NHS
staff cancer treatment rates in the most
recent month for which we have data are
now back at pre-pandemic levels with a
plan for them to increase further and
recently the NHS also announced plans to
fast-track patients direct to cancer
tests rather than have to wait for
specialist consultation first these
measures will make a difference and I
look forward to updating on them in the
New Year Terry Robinson thank you Mr
Speaker with the closure of the last
bank in Cheadle yet another of my local
communities has been left totally bereft
over High Street banking service so I
was pleased when I heard the
announcement that Sheila was to get a
banking hub
unfortunately my delight was short-lived
when on closer inspection I saw the
Jewish Cheadle Staffordshire
whilst I remain pleased for the other
Cheadle would my right honorable friend
agree with me that my constituents also
lead to access to cash and banking
facilities to protect businesses and
support our High Street and will he
support our local pause for post office
banking hubs I missed my uh honorable
friend is a fantastic Champion for
Cheadle in Greater Manchester she will
she will know that the financial
services and markets bill will establish
a legislative framework for protecting
access to cash and alongside this uh
firms are already working to provide
shared services as she mentioned like
bank cards but what I would encourage
vulnerable friend to do is to contact
link which and which can undertake an
independent assessment of a community's
cash access needs and determine if
shared facilities are appropriate maybe
in Hamilton
Mr Speaker my constituent Sharon has an
11 year old daughter who suffers from
eating disorders and severe anorexia she
was forced to spend a year in hospital
in Sheffield 40 miles away because there
were no beds in leads for children with
those Eating Disorders this Mr Speaker
is completely unacceptable so will the
Prime Minister now commit to ensuring
that NHS mental health provision for
young people is dramatically improved so
that no other family has to ever again
endure similar trauma
well first of all can I say to Sharon
and her family I'm sorry about what
she's experienced The Honorable
gentleman makes an excellent point
mental health funding as he knows is
increasing so we ensure parity of
service he's also right to raise the
issue of Eating Disorders it's something
that provision is currently expanding
for I think 2 000 more children uh were
given the treatment that and the advice
and support they needed last year and
there are plans to go further because
it's an issue that needs tackling
Jason would come thank you Mr Speaker
police Constable Nicola Hughes and PC
Fiona bone were savagely murdered in
Manchester whilst on duty a decade ago
Nicholas dad Brynn is my constituent he
lives in Marsden he was in Parliament
again last week continuing his campaign
for emergency service workers and police
officers who die whilst on duty to be
awarded the Elizabeth medal posthumously
does my right honorable friend agree
with me and Brynn that now is the time
to commemorate and honor our brave
police officers and emergency service
workers who make the ultimate sacrifice
by awarding posthumously the Elizabeth
medal prime minister I thank my
honorable friend for his question and I
thank his constituent Brynn for his
campaigning every life loss in the line
of duty is attract and we remember the
lives and service of PC's Nicola Hughes
and Fiona bone we are determined Mr
Speaker to ensure that sacrifice the
police officers and other Public Service
officers make is recognized and we are
carefully considering the best and most
appropriate ways to do this
they've crashed the economy left
millions in fear of the cold this winter
and our stocking division over striking
workers rather than negotiating fear
videos why is it that the orderly people
that can rely on this prime minister are
questionable PPE suppliers of the House
of Lords bankers and former Prime
Ministers getting taxpayer-funded
handouts to defend their partying
through covet
prime minister
Mr Speaker the the only people stoking
division in our United Kingdom are the
party opposite
12 sir I'm minister
[Music]
Mr Speaker our priorities are growth
investing in public services and giving
businesses the confidence they need to
invest I look forward to discussing this
with the mayor of the West Midlands
vital Publican Mr Speaker when my right
vulnerable friend the Prime Minister
recently visited the national Memorial
Arboretum he was slightly late but I
don't blame him because he had to come
by Road
now my friend the mayor of the West
Midlands is supporting an extension of
the Cross City Line from Birmingham
using an existing freight line to make
it into a rail service to the National
Memorial Arboretum and Beyond so may I
ask my right honorable friend will he
revisit the national Memorial Arboretum
again see the Armed Forces Memorial and
also come to Litchfield and see why we
need a Leisure Center
happened
well uh
I I'd be uh I'd be delighted to come and
visit the National Memorial Arboretum
again see my friend and the Fantastic
mayor of the West Midlands Andy Street
to discuss his plans to drive growth and
opportunity in the region
thank you Mr
speaker it is now well over three three
years since the conservatives promised
the end no fault evictions Enfield has
the highest rate of section 21 evictions
in London 30 families in my constituency
and the last month alone were made
homeless as a result of section 21. I
have families sat in my office trying to
keep warm as we try to find them
emergency accommodation will the Prime
Minister scrap this shameful legislation
if so when
start well Mr Speaker The Honorable lady
will know that we have announced plans
to do that and we await parliamentary
time but it's not but it's not the only
thing we're doing uh to protect renters
uh Mr Speaker
past the legislation all ready to
protect tenants from ripoff fees and
we've kept holding deposits because we
want to make sure that renters do have
the protections that they require and
they have their decent homes to rent
well we've laid them thank you Mr
Speaker small modular reactors are a
hugely important part of our future
energy and this conservative government
realized that when it's awarded
Rolls-Royce nuclear section based in my
constituency a grant 210 pounds for
development but there's still no Clarity
or plan from moving from development to
deployment will the Prime Minister come
with me to meet Rolls-Royce to discuss
how to move things forward and ensure
the UK benefits from this exciting
opportunity stuff all my uh my honorable
phone makes an excellent point I'm
delighted that government has awarded
210 million pounds to Rolls-Royce SMR
last year for research and development
this does have the potential to benefit
the UK and support our energy security
and climate goals I look forward to
getting updates and for working with my
honorable friend to see this fantastic
new technology come to life
when my constituent who has dementia was
taken ill recently it took three hours
for an ambulance to arrive he then spent
10 hours in the back of an ambulance
outside a e queuing to get in the doctor
said to him I'm so sorry we're treating
you out of the back of a truck but as
we've heard the king's fund has said
that the government has presided over a
decade of neglect of managed decline in
the NHS so isn't it the Prime Minister
not that Doctor Who should be
apologizing
[Applause]
Mr Speaker that same Kings fund report
also acknowledged that there was 40 more
funding going into the NHS under this
conservative government but we do need
to make sure that that funding makes a
difference that's why this winter half a
billion pounds is being deployed to move
people out of hospital beds into social
care to speed up those discharges
specifically so that ambulances won't be
queuing as much as they currently are
and that money is already making a
difference on the ground
thank you Mr Speaker to the community in
kingshurst which I represent has
suffered in an unimaginable tragedy
earlier this week when four children
fell through the ice at Babson Lake
sadly three of the children did not
survive and one a six-year-old is
fighting for his life they and their
their families are all in my thoughts
and prayers well my right honorable
friend pay tribute to the community in
Kingston which has come together and is
supporting each other to get through
this tragedy and will you recognize the
heroic efforts of the emergency services
including the police officer who uses
bare hands to try and right through the
eyes and then jumped in the water with
fire service Personnel without the PPE
risking their own life to save the young
children yeah
I thank my honorable friend and can I
send my condolences to the family and
friends of all of those who lost their
lives I also join him in paying tribute
to our emergency services for as he said
they're incredibly selfless actions this
whole event has completely shocked the
local community and I know that my
honorable friend will continue to do all
he can to support his constituents at
this difficult time Dave Angelo Regal
speaker this year the Tory party has
given us five education secretaries four
chancellors three prime ministers two
leadership
[Applause]
and the and Mr Speaker the partridges
had to sell the pear tree to pay the
gifts
so uh Mr Speaker isn't it the case that
after a year of Tory chaos incompetence
and self-indulgence the best Christmas
present the Prime Minister could give to
the British people is a general
foreign
[Applause]
Mr Speaker but all I'd say all I'd say
when it comes to what the British people
need this Christmas Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker in order to ease the disruption
on their lives the best thing that the
party opposite could do is tell their
union bosses to call off these damaging
thank you Mr Speaker after the second
world war Winston Churchill sent British
conservative lawyers to help to draft
the European convention on human rights
and that's something that we can be
proud of in this country but in an age
of mass migration the echr is now
limiting our ability to control our
borders
so in light of the tragedy in the
channel this morning
does the Prime Minister agree he should
do as Churchill did draft a new
framework for refugees and human rights
including legal groups but one way or
another and if necessary alone we must
be prepared to leave the echr
[Music]
[Applause]
an Mr Speaker as I told the house
yesterday our new legislation will
deliver a system whereby a person who
comes here illegally will have no right
to stay and will be removed to their own
country or a safe Third Country
alternative that is the system that the
British people want to see that's a
system that we will deliver and I look
forward to hearing whether the party
opposite will support it
thank you Mr Speaker as temperatures are
plummeting and the cost of living crisis
is deepening ordinary families are
facing a dickensian nightmare across the
country this Christmas mortgage bills
are soaring household repossessions are
up and nearly half a million tenants
face a threat of eviction after falling
behind on their rent too many people are
worrying about where they and their
children will wake up on Christmas
morning so will the Prime Minister agree
to a temporary ban over the festive
period on repossessions and evictions so
that nobody has to live in fear of
losing their home this Christmas
Mr Speaker we provide a range of support
to both homeowners and tenants who are
in difficulty already but the most
important thing we are doing to
financially support them through the
winter is by providing almost 900 pounds
of support with their energy bills on
top of all the additional support for
those who are most vulnerable including
pensioners that demonstrates the actions
of this government to help the country
get through what we acknowledge is a
challenging time Stephen
tomorrow Mr Speaker at 9 30 you'll lead
this house in a one minute silence to
Mark 80 years since the British
government recognized that the Holocaust
was taking place in Nazi occupied Europe
as we come together to mark that moment
will the Prime Minister join me in
praising the Holocaust educational trust
and the extraordinary survivors who
continue to do amazing work ensuring
that the Next Generation understand and
learn the lessons from the past
Mr Speaker 80 years ago Parliament
listened in stunned silence as the truth
of the Holocaust was spoken in this
house for the very first time so it's
absolutely right that you Mr Speaker
lead a moment of silence in which we
will stand together to remember and
reaffirm that truth I joined my
honorable friend in paying tribute to
the work of the Holy forced educational
trust and it could not be more fitting
than Britain's Holocaust Memorial and
learning center should be built right
next door to here to Parliament we must
never forget the Holocaust and we would
Stamp Out anti-Semitism and Prejudice in
all its forms wherever we find it Chris
Evans thank you Mr Speaker to Philly
County Borough Council recently
announced a three million pound cost of
living hardship fund to help those most
in need in this line and across our
County Barra does the Prime Minister
think it's right that local authorities
are forced to cover the costs of 12
Years of economic mismanagement by this
Tory government
Mr Speaker what the honorable gentleman
fails to acknowledge is that because of
the actions of this UK government not
only are we supporting people in Wales
and across the United Kingdom with help
with their energy bills we've also
provided 1.2 billion pounds of extra
funding for the Welsh government to use
to give to local authorities to support
their constituents and he would do well
to acknowledge the benefits of the
United Kingdom and the actions of the UK
government
we have a record 4 000 newly qualified
doctors training to be GPS which is
really excellent but we do have an issue
with retention which is made even worse
in areas like mine which have extremely
high housing growth as a son of a GP
what will the Prime Minister do to fix
this
prime minister well um Mr Speaker I know
this is a an issue that my honorable
friend has talked and championed for a
long term and he's right to do so we do
have record numbers of GPS in training
at the moment we're also making sure
that we support Primary Care
appointments and Primary Care access and
I know that my normal friendly Health
secretary and Chancellor are looking at
how best we can increase retention
particularly with regard to pensions and
I look forward to getting his
suggestions final question Wendy
Chamberlain thank you Mr Speaker in a
written response from the DWP it was
confirmed to me that an unpaid carer
earning more than 132 pounds a week in
their job is classed as being in gainful
employment and as a result loses their
carers allowance of 69.70 a week now
caring doesn't stop it never stops so
can the Prime Minister explain to me the
rationale of this decision given that we
are trying to get economically and
active people back into work and
secondly can he explain why it's his
government's position that 132 times a
week is enough for people to live on
prime minister
Mr Speaker can I first start by paying
tribute to those up and down the country
who give up so much of their time to
care for others and I'm actually
delighted that the government is
supporting The Honorable members bill
which will give a week of Highly
flexible paid leave to unemployed carers
I think it's the right thing to do and
I'm grateful that The Honorable lady is
taking it forward a carous allowance is
a means tested benefit is part of many
other benefits that are available to
support people and as I've said right
now there are significant support in
place for people through Christmas with
their energy bills complete prime
minister's questions just let the house
clear
right let's just come to the statement
them secretary
[Applause]
with Mission Mr Speaker I would like to
make a statement about an incident in
the channel this morning
this is an ongoing search and rescue
incident but I can confirm that at the
time of making this statement tragically
there have been four fatalities
it would be an appropriate Mr Speaker
for me to go into further detail at this
time
there is a multi-agency response to this
terrible tragedy his Majesty's Coast
Guard the rnli South East Coast
Ambulance the ministry of Defense police
and Border Force together with French
vessels and a commercial fishing vessels
and contractors at Western jet fall have
responded this morning Mr Speaker I have
spoken to borderforth officials based at
Dover manston and involved in the search
and rescue effort I've also spoken to my
French counterpart the interior Minister
Gerald Domin
a full statement will be provided to the
house in due course once the facts have
been fully established and the necessary
investigative work completed
I know that everyone in this house and
across the country will join me in
expressing our profound sadness and
deepest sympathies for everyone affected
by this terrible event
I know that they will also join me in
offering our profound gratitude to those
working on the search and rescue
operation
that very much includes those who are
responding to The Incident Commander Dan
omahani and his team